[Music]
hello there
my name is bradley and this is some sub
a channel on how to survive in the
online jungle
so if you ever wondered how much of your
computer or smartphone's computing power
is actually being spent on security
bear in mind all the information that we
say download from the network or the
information that we exchange with
another it's all protected by advanced
encryption methods in an investigation
on cicada3301 i spoke in detail about
the use of classical encryption methods
now most of these methods can actually
be cracked through simple brute force
attacks of course that takes a lot of
time when done manually but with the
advent of modern computers caesars or
visionaires ciphers are as easy to crack
as say just a few mathematical puzzles
well today we're going to be using
fundamentally different algorithms
complex and repetitive transformations
reliably protect themselves from brute
force attacks encryption keys have
turned into huge sequences of numbers
now only keys with a size of 128 bits
are actually considered reliable but
that doesn't sound very impressive does
it but in fact it gives
340
undecillion combinations it's really
impossible to sort them out in a
reasonable amount of time but you know
something interesting throughout the
history of the development of computer
technology we've been consistently faced
with the fact that what was impossible
yesterday becomes somewhat obsolete
tomorrow
nevertheless our whole life depends on
the reliability of encryption
whether you're talking love
correspondence on facebook to bank
payments worth many billions of dollars
so today i'd like to talk about the real
threats to ciphers that we use every
single day and about a fundamentally new
security system that you might not have
heard of
sounds pretty cool quantum cryptography
and i promise in advance today
no cat will suffer
[Music]
well let's start with the simplest
cipher do you remember the creation of
gaius julius caesar
well the great commander simply shifted
all of the letters in the message by the
same number of characters for example
when you shift by three letters
something like a turns into d
b into e and so on when you're using the
alphabet as the key now look at this
intercepted message y x v b j n h w imp
y t v b t g m s by d m x l z t b n l b l
v we don't know how many steps the
letters in this message are shifted by
but we do know the principle of the
encryption suppose the second line is
caesar's signature in order for i to
turn into g it needs to be shifted by 19
letters let's check the following
letters and get gaius we're not mistaken
and now we can easily decipher the
entire message so translated caesar's
message reads i did what i could made
those who are able do better
you see we didn't have to go through all
26 possible shift options sequentially
if we spent only a minute checking each
of them then we would probably get the
right one in almost a quarter of an hour
and so we cracked this cipher in just a
minute and a half or without even
knowing the original language of the
message itself piece of cake well
[Music]
now an interesting question remains is
it possible to make this cipher more
reliable
yes for example you can complicate the
key
if we agree that the letters in the
message will shift by the number of
letters in the key it will become much
more difficult to reveal the cipher
itself so let's encrypt the word caesar
c is the third letter of the alphabet so
we'll shift it by three characters
a is the first so
that one step and so on as a result we
get an incomprehensible achi now let's
apply that same principle to the
original message
you see here it's much more difficult to
decipher it and please note that the
word caesar was actually encrypted
differently to last time the change
number of letters before the initials is
actually to blame here our key is
shorter than the message and we have to
write it down again and again we have to
encode it
the number of letters in the message
will change and the initials themselves
will also change ideally if a key has
the same length as a message the cipher
will be impossible to find each letter
will move to its own step without
repetitions and patterns and even
knowing the encryption principle won't
help at all to crack the code itself we
have an excellent and reliable algorithm
why don't we just use that well it's all
about the key
now in order for the recipient of the
message to be able to decrypt it he or
she they must have the same key as you
now in addition the keys must be changed
after each use now if you're often
meeting with the address c then handing
over the keys really isn't a problem
although then it's probably easier to
just send messages without an encryption
in the first place you can actually act
like real spies and stock up on a supply
of keys in advance and this is called a
one-time pad now indeed you will need to
meet in a safe space but just once and
then you'll use such a page of such pad
to work with codes and immediately
destroy it after use now that is
reliable but it's inconvenient the keys
run out quickly so this method only
really works for rare communication
sessions and small messages
[Music]
now in real life a combined approach
tends to be used the keys are actually
much shorter than the text of the
message but the encryption algorithm
itself
is actually much more complicated now
the letters are recorded many times in a
row and in quite a complex way and
that's without mentioning that they
actually affect the location of one
another now many of these operations
were extremely problematic to perform so
by the middle of the 20th century
electro-mechanical encryption machines
were widely used surely you've heard
about the german enigma more than once
now this code was considered uncrackable
but british cryptographers from
bletchley park still managed to crack it
now the germans themselves were partly
to blame here they made mistakes when
using keys they wrote predictable
messages and so on but the main thing is
that a group of scientists led by alan
turing managed to create a huge machine
that sorted through all possible
passwords
you can see here this is alan turing's
machine three meter cabinet filled with
wires electric motors and relays the
brain of the machine is 108 rotating
drums which imitated the enigma
encryption disks this machine was going
through several hundred possible
combinations every single minute the
discs clicked like the clockwork
mechanism of an explosive device so the
machine was actually called the turing
bomb
to cope with the description of german
messages it was necessary actually to
build 210 of such machines
pretty impressive and i look at the
screen you see this spreadsheet it's
about 200 kilobytes that is probably
less than my facebook profile picture
and at the same time the table
completely replaces both the enigma and
the turing bomb
now think about it one spreadsheet
replaces the entire turing mechanical
computing sensor 520 tons of copper and
steel we're talking about the
unbreakable code of the second world war
is decoded in the blink of an eye
in plain old excel
of course since the time of turing new
encryption algorithms with secret keys
have also appeared and these obviously
have their advantages they're the
fastest and easiest to implement and are
quite reliable when using long and
random keys but unfortunately they're
completely unsuitable for a modern
network just imagine that before making
a purchase on amazon or subscribing to
netflix you would have to go through the
procedure of obtaining special unique
keys and you'd have to all do it offline
by mail or courier
e-commerce would look very different and
i think jeff bezos would
not have a chance of being in space
[Music]
fortunately there was a revolution in
cryptography in the early 70s first a
model was created and then a successful
encryption algorithm with a public key
imagine that you want to send i don't
know a briefcase by mail but you want to
make it so that nobody can intercept it
along the way i suppose you take a
strong box and put the briefcase in the
box and maybe close it with a padlock
can you see where the problem is
without a key the recipient of the
parcel will not be able to open the lock
we don't have the key we can't open
whatever it is we don't have that it
unlocks so what purpose would be served
in finding whatever need be unlocked
which we don't have without first having
found the key one losses and if you're
afraid to actually send the key with it
what should you do well everything's
pretty simple you send a briefcase with
a lock and you keep the key for yourself
now when that briefcase arrives at your
friend's house he will not try to open
it but instead he will add his own lock
onto the briefcase and he'll then send
it back to you when you receive it
you'll remove your lock with your key
and now the briefcase remains locked
only by your friend's lock so you send
it back to him here the lock is locked
and then that's done the case traveled
three times but you managed to ensure
reliable transmission of the contents
without having any information about
each other's keys now obviously this
idea is great but
well it's pretty mathematically
unrealizable it's impossible to decrypt
a message with one key bypassing the
second encryption unlike the lock on the
case each encryption changes the content
to the package itself but the story of
the briefcase inspired mathematicians
and they began to look for an analog of
the system with two independent locks
the research resulted in public key
encryption systems now in such a system
each user creates two keys at once first
secret one which will be only used by
its owner and this key is generated
based on random set of numbers right and
then a second key is paired with it
which can be published in open form now
only one public key can correspond to
one private key and it's easy to
calculate the public key but it's almost
impossible to find out the private key
from it and this is somewhat similar to
exponentiation you could probably square
17 in your mind but you wouldn't be able
to swiftly find the square root 5832.
we've already talked about such
algorithms in a series dedicated to
cryptocurrencies so re-watch that if you
forgot about it so now i've got a pair
of keys
secret and public now when someone wants
to send me a message they encrypt the
text using a well-known key but it can
only be decrypted with a linked secret
key
returning to the algae with locks it's
as if i sent a bunch of
blocks to everyone in the world right
and they're all opened locks but they
don't have keys now if you want to send
me a parcel simply put one of these
public locks on it
now no one else will be able to open it
apart from me because i have the master
key now you use this exact thing
hundreds of times every day now every
time you visit https websites you see
that lock on the address bar right
perhaps if you're connecting to wi-fi or
entering a pin code at the payment
terminal
you're using it
now programs on your computer or
smartphone constantly exchange public
keys and use them to create secure
communication channels there is a
fundamental problem with this algorithm
to actually generate the keys the task
of decomposing huge numbers into a pair
of prime factors is most often used and
for cryptographic tasks numbers with
several hundred characters are used now
to quickly sort out the multipliers of
such a number that's an impossible task
even for modern supercomputers and
therein lies the problem so there's
various shortcuts that people found to
quickly be able to determine whether
something is a prime number
but no one has
found a shortcut to be able to find the
actual prime factors unfortunately we're
not talking about only the computers
we're familiar with
not those ones with binary architecture
[Music]
we are now on the threshold of a new
revolution the appearance of computers
based on fundamentally different
physical principles now i'm talking
about quantum computers this is peter
shaw an outstanding american
mathematician and also the author of the
first algorithm that should demonstrate
the supremacy of quantum computers over
say conventional ones now by a strange
coincidence shaw's algorithm can
actually be used to attack popular
public key encryption systems in 1994 it
seemed like science fiction but already
in 2001 the ibm computer was able to
decompose the number 15 into its prime
factors three years ago the national
academies of sciences engineering and
medicine predicted that a powerful
quantum computer would actually be able
to crack a 10 24 bit encryption key in
less than 24 hours none of our classic
computers would actually be able to do
this task our sun would probably go out
before then write the prime
factorization of 75 write your answer
using exponential notations we have to
think about that
return to this place in exactly
seven and a half million years
such an incredible gap in performance is
due to the fact that quantum computers
do not sort out solutions but rather
choose them from all possible options
it's kind of like your computer trying
to put together a puzzle with existing
pieces now computers with binary logic
will sequentially iterate through all
possible combinations the quantum
computer on the other hand already
contains all possible combinations of
the puzzle elements we just need to
understand which one is right for us and
just with the selection of prime factors
the criteria for this choice are very
easy to determine now while there are
only a few quantum computers in
existence most of them are generally
designed to solve one specific task each
but on the other hand the guys at google
promised to provide commercial access to
their quantum monster in as early as
2029 some cyber security experts already
discussing a new ideology post-quantum
cryptography recently the first
algorithm designed to counteract a
quantum supercomputer has already
appeared
and it's so symbolic that the authors
have called it new hope
indeed quantum computer science in
addition to its related threats brings
new approaches to solving old problems
one of them is secure key exchange
now although the name of this technology
again uses the word quantum it's not
related to quantum computers at part of
this technology is another concept of
quantum mechanics the fundamental
fragility of the photon
take a look at this ordinary samsung
ball
regardless of whether i'm looking at it
or not in the room at all this ball will
still be lying in exactly the same place
but with elementary particles everything
is not so for example a single photon
can fly through two different slits at
once it can emit high and low energy at
the same time it can rotate clockwise
and counterclockwise at the same time
before we try to measure these
quantities you need to understand the
particle has all of these properties
this cocktail of states is called a
superposition as soon as we perform
measurement the superposition disappears
the particle goes into one of the
probable states it's no longer possible
to return the particle to the
superposition states and this is an
irreversible process right it's like
bursting a bubble of soap the very act
of trying to measure your
position prevents me from measuring your
position and it does have jack [ __ ] to
do with your consciousness or your mind
or your eyes or anything now this is the
basis for secure transfer of secret keys
when transmitting order information a
series of short pulses are used almost
like morse code when the transmitter is
working it's a one and when it's not
working it's a zero standard binary data
but for quantum transmission individual
photons are actually used each of which
carries much more information firstly a
photon can have a horizontal or a
vertical polarization and these
effectively make up our zeros and ones
in our system and secondly when
transmitting data you can actually
rotate the polarizer at an angle of 45
degrees and these two positions with
polarizer are called bases
now the center of the secret key will
randomly decide to use a straight or
diagonal basis before each new character
the receiver of the message will also
randomly set the basis before receiving
a new photon according to probability
theory their choice will coincide in
half of the cases the rest of that
information will be lost after the end
of the key transfer the recipient will
tell you which bases he used to decrypt
the key the sender will then compare
them with their results and tell you
which bases were chosen correctly now
it's those values that will be the key
for future correspondence now this key
can be used to transfer data on any open
network but why complicate the system so
much
well simple answer to exclude the
possibility of eavesdropping on messages
any observer will not be able to
determine the state of the photon
without actually altering the
superposition state in addition the spy
will have to guess the bases that were
chosen by the sender as a result if the
recipient's error rate increases to
something like 75 percent well the key
will be considered compromised and it
will be transmitted through another
channel what gets interesting with
quantum communications is whenever we
add an eavesdropper into the mix i'm
going to shift this equipment in here
which is going to simulate an
eavesdropper trying to listen in on our
conversation whenever the sender
receives a message you'll see both
lights light up on the detector
what that indicates is that the middle
man cannot tell what the sender sent
this algorithm was developed back in the
late 1980s but only in recent years has
gone beyond the laboratories now today
quantum communication lines are being
experimented within europe and america
and
china well they launched their first
national network this year
4 600 kilometers of fiber connected
about 150 different banks defense
enterprises and government agencies the
encryption key transfer rate was 47
kilobits per second and that's quite
enough for streaming encryption key
changes
[Music]
in the 20th century cryptography
received the status of a science for the
first time before the enigma hacking
story decrypting other people's codes
was well more of an art than an exact
science alan turing effectively brought
rigorous mathematical methods to the
world of cryptography assumptions and
insights were replaced by methods of
mathematical statistics and game theory
now the volume of transmitted data is
growing faster than the computing power
of computers and also the bandwidth of
networks and therefore the problem of
optimizing encryption algorithms is
becoming more and more serious in
addition the advent of quantum computers
threatens to leave behind usual methods
of encryption such as public keys now
it's time to think about fundamentally
new algorithms of the post quantum era
i'd also recommend taking a closer look
at the shares of quantum network
providers well ladies and gentlemen it's
been swell my name is of course bradley
your reliable guide through the
bewildering and wild winds of the
worrisome online jungle i'll see you in
the next video have a good one
[Music]
you